good morning Hank it's Monday today I
want to talk about the first chapter of
the Great Gatsby which is often called
the Great American Novel not so much for
its greatness or its novelist but
because of its american-ness so in the
last sixty years the United States has
been very successful at exporting ideas
like the idea of inexpensive hamburgers
and also the idea of the American dream
you know the American dream it's the
idea that everyone regardless of
standing in life has an equal
opportunity to become successful which
in the United States generally means
rich the Great Gatsby is in many ways a
novel about the American dream but it's
also more Universal than that because
one we've done a really good job of
exporting the American dream and also to
the American Dream was actually never
that uniquely American it's actually
kind of a universal dream these days but
one of the charming things about
Americans is that we see things that
belong to the world and then we're like
that's American ok so in the first few
pages of the Great Gatsby here's what we
know about our faithful narrator Nick
Carraway by the way get it care away 1
he used to live in the Midwest then he
moved to New York and now he's back in
the Midwest something happened in New
York that made him go home - he's a
little bit highfalutin with words Nick
hansip what made him leave New York and
introduces us to Gatsby the hero of the
novel insofar as Gatsby can be called
heroic by saying Gatsby turned out all
right in the end it was what preyed on
Gatsby what foul dust floated in the
wake of his dreams that temporarily
closed out my interest in the abortive
sorrows and short-winded elations of men
in short Gatsby was ok but his dream his
American dream was a little troubling
the third thing we know about Nick
Carraway is that he's rich and how did
he get rich not by living the American
dream but instead the old-fashioned way
by having a rich ancestor we earned this
ancestor paid someone off to serve in
the Civil War and while that poor sap
was fighting Nick's ancestor was busy
making money how's that for an American
dream so Nick moves to New York to work
in the bond business and he gets a house
on West Egg which is one of two almost
identical islands West Egg being the
less fashionable one nickel is in kind
of a ramshackle house but both of his
next-door neighbors are millionaires
including the titular great gatsby about
whom we learn almost nothing in Chapter
1 except that he had an extraordinary
gift for hope that's the essential fact
of Gatsby and also all romantic leads
that have come since like I don't care
if you're talking about Edward Cullen or
the dude from the notebook or Miles
halter all of them share an
extraordinary gift for hope right all of
them share this almost creepy belief
that if I can just
what I dream of I'll be happy but we
don't think much of Gatsby in Chapter
one instead we need Tom and Daisy
Buchanan and Daisy is like Nick's second
cousin once removed and he goes over to
East Egg the fashionable place where
they live in order to have like the
worst dinner ever so Daisy Buchanan's
like a professional pretty person and
Tom Buchanan is a former football player
who Fitzgerald describes perfectly by
saying that he was one of those men who
achieved such an acute limited
excellence at twenty one that everything
afterwards savers of anticlimax if
you're not yet 21 you may not be able to
understand what a burn that is but trust
me it's a burn the Buchanan's are also
crazy rich like polo pony rich you'll be
surprised to learn how they got rich
unless you guessed that it was not by
living the American dream
also take note of this their house
golden rights and knickers are there to
meet Daisy and Tom there's also this
rather hot girl there named Jordan Baker
they just have a horrible dinner Daisy
is aggressively vapid midway through
dinner Tom goes on this horrible racist
rant he says the idea is that we're
Nordics and we've produced all the
things that make a civilization
meanwhile they haven't produced to
anything they're at a dinner where they
didn't make the food they're eating they
don't even like their own freaking
candles that Alana's more set more than
rain on your wedding day or 10,000
spoons when all you need is a knife is
irony but then everything changes when
the phone rings Daisy and Tom leave
Jordan Baker explains to Nick that Tom
has some woman in New York and then you
start to realize that maybe these people
who have it all don't a little bit later
in a conversation with Nick Daisy says
one of the most interesting things in
the book Daisy wakes up after giving
birth and Tom has left and she looks at
her daughter and says I hope she'll be a
fool that's the best thing a girl can be
in this world a beautiful little fool
she's trying to be a beautiful little
fool because that's the only way she can
see to get through life one of the most
interesting things about this chapter is
that we are in fashionable East Egg in
the center of the world with the richest
people on earth and their polo ponies
and no one is having any fun
Nick leaves the awful dinner he goes
home and at the end of chapter one we
catch our first glimpse of the Great
Gatsby he's standing outside his house
arms stretched in the night looking in
the distance and Nick follows his gaze
and sees out over the bay a single green
light that green white has become one of
the most important metaphors in American
later
so watch out for does he keep reading
one other thing about midway through the
chapter Daisy tells the story of how her
Butler used to work as a silver polisher
for a big family in New York and he
would polish silver morning noon and
night and then eventually he had to quit
because the stinky carcinogens ruined
his nose if the whole first chapter is
about how wealth consumes the rich that
little anecdote is a reminder that well
consumes the poor as well so here's your
first non rhetorical question do you
think the way the great gatsby portrays
luxury and wealth and the American Dream
accurately reflects the truth about
those things I mean both in the Jazz Age
when the book is set and today you'll
find a link in the doobly-doo to a
thread in your pants to continue the
conversation Hank I'll see you on
Wednesday